Understanding the ethnic
and religious commonalities
and differences in the
state or the region that
used to be Yugoslavia
can be quite confusing.
What I want to do in this video
is try to give a primer on it.
It's really key to understanding
some of the triggers of World
War I. And to, obviously,
understand the breakup
of Yugoslavia which was
quite ugly during the fall
of Communism in the late
'80s and early '90s.
So first of all,
it's a good idea
to just understand where the
word Yugoslavia comes from.
It's literally referring to
the southern Slavic states.
So Yugo- is referring
to southern.
And -slavia, we're talking
about the Slavic states.
And when people talk
about Slavic languages,
they're talking about
the languages that
are spoken in this region, but
also much of Eastern Europe,
and in what is now Russia.
Now, what we have
here in blue is,
we have shaded in
where Serbo-Croatian
is spoken, which is the dominant
Slavic language in this region.
And there are multiple dialects.
Some people will say, oh,
it's Croatian or Montenegrin
or Serbian or
whatever it might be.
But mostly, linguists
say, well, they're
pretty close to each other.
And you can categorize them as
one language as Serbo-Croatian.
And you see that it's now spoken
in modern day Croatia, Bosnia
and Herzegovina,
Serbia and Montenegro.
And that is the
commonality here,
the thing that ties
together this region.
Now on top of that,
the Slovenian language
is also Slavic language
that is closely related
to Serbo-Croatian.
In Macedonia, they also
speak a Slavic language.
It's closer to Bulgarian.
But it has some close ties.
It's not completely different
than Serbo-Croatian.
So you have this
linguistic connection
throughout this area.
Now, what divides this area is
really religion and history.
So this area, if you look,
go back hundreds of years,
it was under the control
of various empires,
the Austro-Hungarian
Empire, the Ottoman Empire.
Different-- the
Austro-Hungarian Empire,
you're dealing with the
Roman Catholic Empire.
When you're talking
about the Ottomans,
you're dealing with
the Muslim Empire.
And they held in different
parts of this territory
for hundreds of years.
And so what you end up, is
really a mix of religions.
And that often gets tied to
people's-- what they perceive
as also their ethnicities.
And so what I have
here is a break down,
the religious
breakdown of the state,
the former state of Yugoslavia.
So in this pinkish
color right over here,
I have the areas that are
predominately Roman Catholic.
And I say, predominantly,
because it really is all mixed
together.
So Slovenia, Croatia,
primarily Roman Catholic.
If you look at Serbia
and Montenegro,
primarily Eastern Orthodox.
Kosovo, you have a strong Muslim
majority right over there.
And it really gets-- and
Kosovo, before its break up,
was kind of part of
Serbia and Montenegro.
Despite it having this very
different religious makeup.
And then, Bosnia
and Herzegovina is
where things get
really, really mixed up.
Roughly half of the
population, and it's
been moving over the centuries.
But the dominant
religion there is Islam.
And in general, and this is
where it can be confusing,
when people talk
about a Bosniak,
when they're talking
they're talking about
a Bosnian Muslim.
But Bosnia and Herzegovina
also has significant fractions
of Serbs who are
Eastern Orthodox.
So that's why I put
the brown here as well.
It's about a third
of the population.
And it also has a pretty sizable
Roman Catholic population.
Or we could say Bosnian Croats.
So just to be clear here,
it can be very confusing.
Even when you when
you hear history of it
or when you've heard
it on the news.
I remember the '90s
hearing this on the news
and getting very confused.
If someone's referring to a
Bosnian Muslim or Bosniak,
that's a Muslim
living in Bosnia.
That's they tend
to be referring to.
If they say a
Bosnian Croats, this
would be an ethnically Croat
who is living in Bosnia.
And they are-- it would
tend to be Roman Catholic.
And then if you
have a Bosnian Serb,
this is someone who ethnically
identifies themselves
as a Serbian or as
a Serb who lives
in Bosnia and Herzegovina.
But is probably going
to be Eastern Orthodox.
So you can imagine, you have
the strong linguistic and even
ethnic ties.
But at some point, because
of the religion and dialect
changes, there's also
significant amount
of differences here.
Especially when things
got ugly, as you
have the fall of Communism.
So hopefully, this
lays the groundwork
of the commonalities and
the differences here.
And it'll help us understand
what got us into World War I,
or at least what triggered
World War I. And also some
of the ugliness that was
seen in the early '90s.
And just to finish up with
a little bit of context,
this was not a unified
state until-- World War
I, to some degree, was
precipitated by a desire
to make this a unified state.
This ethnic grouping,
this linguistic grouping
tended to be broken up with
the Austro-Hungarian Empire,
the Ottoman Empire.
Entering into a World
War I, you started
to have the decline
of the Ottoman Empire
which started to allow
these people to start
to have more energy behind their
desire to form a unified state.
World War I was
essentially the catalyst
that allowed the state
of Yugoslavia to unify.
And in different
forms, it stayed
unified until the
fall of Communism.
And even though it
was a socialist state,
a communist state
during the Cold War,
it actually always had a
strange and distant relationship
with the Soviet Union.
But after the fall
of Communism, that
was kind of holding it
together, these, especially
these religious
differences, frankly,
and these ethnic and religious
differences broke it apart.